now again really quickly thinking about
how to use this other one
to prove something is true what do we
call this does anyone know
we've actually um talked about this
briefly before
when you're using the negation we call
this proof by
contradiction very good now the reason
why i did this one second
even though we learnt about this idea
earlier is because
the logic of it's much less
straightforward here it's just like
tell me what the contrapositive is and
then off you go okay
how do we do this with the negation
it's all in the name isn't it right we
want to try and start with the negation
you lead to a contradiction and you're
like well this can't be true
so the negation's false which means the
original statement
is true makes sense so let's do i think
i think i'm going to fit it
let's do another classic example it's so
classic it's literally like word for
word
in the syllabus we want to prove that
log base 2 of 5 and you could have
picked a whole bunch of different
numbers but this is kind of like a
classic one
prove that this is irrational
now this time rather than walking you
through this
partly because this is so quick right
i'm going to let you have a little more
time to play with this one but i will
just remind you
of what's the framework for this okay we
are going to try and prove this
by contradiction what's an irrational
number again
irrational something written
very good so irrational means it's not
rational and of course rational means
you could say there's a ratio that's why
the word is what it is
okay now this is log base two of five
two point three two one nine two eight
zero nine and so on oh
okay now it comes in five now
we know that rational numbers can have
very very long decimal expansions but
eventually
they will repeat or they'll terminate
right it's like after this i just
decided to stop i wanted to have a lot
of decimals just not that many
this does go on forever but who knows
like maybe just takes a million decimal
places
and then it starts repeating again we
can prove that that's actually not the
case without going to
any number of decimals that was a
spoiler by the way you don't need any
decimal notation
for this to prove something my
contradiction we've got to start with
the
negation just like with this we've got
to state the negation quite clearly know
what we're dealing with there
as the name suggests you want to lead
from that negation to
something contradictory try your hand at
it
give you maybe five minutes five to ten
minutes to have a play and then we'll
come back together
good luck right so let's
uh let's see if we can pack this into
something which
makes sense or doesn't make sense fun
fact
the um the latin name for proof by
contradiction is delightful
it is reductio ad absurdum you're like
expelliarmus like what does that mean
you're trying to reduce
your argument to something absurd
ridiculous
contradictory and then you can say if
it's
if it's contradictory then the premise
you begin with
can't be true so we know that the
negation and the original implication
have to have opposite truth values and
that's that's the gut to our proof
let's have a go most of you have gotten
this far
pretty sure log base 2 of 5
is to be the negation rational that's
the opposite
right if it's not irrational it's
rational
so if i start from this what i want to
try and do is go from here to something
that i know is not true and then that's
that means that the original theme must
be true okay so to be
rational and i kind of clued you into
this right i should be able to write
this
log base 2 or 5 i should be able to
write it as
a ratio between two integers do you
agree with that
i should be able to say it's for example
a over b you might have used m and
n you might have used p and q doesn't
matter i do need to say what kinds of
numbers a
and b are what kind of numbers could a
and b
be now it's a natural thing
to say a b
are integers uh in fact that is like all
rational numbers
fit this quality however i'm going to
say
a little bit further than that because i
actually know
like the integers are a big set of
numbers well it's an infinitely large
set of numbers
actually half of it is not interesting
to me because i know the value the
decimal
expansion of log base 2 of 5 already so
for reasons that i hope we come clear in
a minute
i'm going to actually restrict this to
the positive
integers some people will say the
natural numbers
it's a bit tricky there because some
people include zero in the natural
numbers some people do not
so i'm just gonna make it completely
unambiguous i'm talking one two three
four and so on
okay all right i've made a statement
that
leads from my negation what can i do
with this and the answer is
uh not a whole lot and maybe you guys
are trying to throw things against the
wall approach and see what sticks
how could you rewrite this log equation
to look like
anything else so you can manipulate
the power a over it 5 is equal to
there's the base from my log and then i
raise it to
my power because that's what logarithmic
notation means
okay this is good this is true several
of you got to this point and you're like
yeah but now what
like great but how do i get from here to
something
non-sensical what could i do with this
frame what are you going to go to next
raised everything to the power b
so in other words what you've done is is
this
is that what you've done okay so once
you do this step right what do you end
up with on the left hand side
5 to the power of b what do you end up
with on the right hand side
yeah these these b's will cancel so you
end up with
this now i wonder how many of you got to
this point and thought
and where do i go with this now just
because i've run out of space down here
i'm just going to talk this out with you
this is the contradictory line this is
the absurd thing here right
what are the powers of 2 2 4 8 16 32 64
128 and so on right
what are the powers of five 525 125
625 you know what you can tell me
instantly about all the powers of two
they're all even of course they are all
even because
the only factors they have are going to
come from two which is an even number
what can you tell me about all the
powers of five they're all going to be
odd because you're starting with an odd
factor and that's all you're multiplying
by again and again again
so what i'm saying is there's some
number that's odd
it's equal to some other number that's
even
i've arrived this is my contradict and
that's what i'm going to state
underneath this since
since i can get that contradiction and
you should right away write you know
i've got the left hand side being odd
and the right hand side apparently being
even
that is the substance of my
contradiction that means
our premise can't possibly be true
because it leads to this
absurd situation the premise
is false the negation is false that
means the original
implication is true are you happy with
the logic of how that flows
like i said this is a classic it's in
the syllabus uh this particular one
mercifully it's short but you do need to
understand how it works